im hässischen Homberg FC macht bolorma
eine Ausbildung zur Pflegerin die junge
Mongolin darf in den ersten sech Monaten
nach ihre Ankunft mit dem Auto zum
Einsatz fahren alles prima aber nach
einem halben Jahr wird ihr Führerschein
von den deutschen Behörden für ungültig
erklärt das verstehe ich einfach nicht
ne warum die erste se Monaten kann
könnte ich fahren und dann nach 6
Monaten nicht 2021 ist BMA in
Deutschland dass der Führerschein nach 6
Monaten weg ist ist nicht nur für sie
ein Problem genau wie ihr geht es
insgesamt
mongolischen Auszubildenden sie wurden
alle in der Mongolei angeworben um den
Pflegenotstand zu lindern einige haben
über 10 Jahre
Fahrpraxis das Problem die
Fahrerlaubnisverordnung die Pflegekräfte
aus der Mongolei dürfen 6 Monate lang
Autofahren danach müssen sie plötzlich
einen deutschen Führerschein vorlegen
unmöglich denn neben der Arbeit neben
dem Deutsch büffeln mal eben noch den
deutschen Führerschein machen das
schafft hier
niemand das ist nicht nachvollziehbar
das ist nicht zu verstehen das können
wir als ambulanter Pflegedienst wo wir
so dringend auf Fachkräfte auch
angewiesen sind nicht
nachvollziehen das
Bundesverkehrsministerium teilt uns mit
es geh alles streng nach Recht und
Gesetz schriftlich heißt es es muss
sichergestellt sein dass der Inhaber
einer ausländischen Fahrerlaubnis auch
unter den in Deutschland bestehenden
Verkehrsverhältnissen in der Lage ist
ein Fahrzeug sicher zu
führen mit anderen Worten für die
mongolischen Pflegekräfte gibt's keine
Hilfe für Sie und Ihre Patienten eine
Katastrophe ich würde dafür sein dass
man die mit einer Sonderregelung fahren
l sie können ja fahren also ich halte
dass wir total blöd sind die sollen den
mongolischen Mädchen die Führerschein
lassen weil die können alle schon fahren
wgen dem Führerschein möchte ich nicht
meine Motivation und Kraft verloren und
auch meine Ausbildung möchte ich nicht
aufgeben beim Homberger Pflegedienst
hofft man jetzt dass man im
Bundesverkehrsministerium endlich zur
Besinnung kommt und die Verordnung
ändert sonst verliert man Pflegekräfte
die nicht nur in Homberg ganz dringend
gebraucht werden